una marea de banderas estadounidenses y
gorras make américa great siguen miles
de seguidores del derrotado candidato
republicano donald trump se reunieron en
washington dc para mostrar su apoyo al
presidente
víctima de un robo electoral creo en él
ha hecho más por este país en 4 años que
cualquier presidente es genial y lo amo
y estoy aquí para defender tiempo
el propio mandatario saludó a los
manifestantes sonriendo a través de la
ventanilla de su coche blindado el
titular republicano se aferra a las
desacreditadas afirmaciones de fraude
masivo y asegura que derrotó al
presidente elector jobvite en obligarlo
ya no tenemos control de nuestro propio
destino y hay una gran corrupción por
parte de bailén y todos los medios de
comunicación cuando digo todos quiere
decir literalmente todos con la milicia
de derecha track boys los chicos
orgullosos entre los asistentes se
desplegó una gran presencia de seguridad
para evitar enfrentamientos pero después
de una manifestación pacífica al
atardecer empezaron altercado
entre seguidores y detractores del
presidente saliente según medios locales
se reportaron 10 detenidos y un herido
por apuñalamiento esto no ha terminado
ni siquiera está cerca de terminar y
esta gente que te dice ahora mismo que
se ha acabado te está mintiendo la
votación no ha sido declarada no no hay
presidente electo
a pesar de que las propias autoridades
electorales declararon esta semana que
las elecciones fueron las más seguras en
la historia del país
schwank y sus aliados no muestran signos
de abandonar su búsqueda para conseguir
que los resultados sean anulados